hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play drunk minecraft okay we asked
for your suggestions and Beezer
they so again they kind of do only way
doesn't like them wager today hey build
something kill what else oh my god oh my
god
make make replicas of how you guys see
each other it would just be a big field
of penises honestly Lauren's sweat swet
punch weight off a mountain awesome it's
I'm not that much of a fan of hurting
you wait um who said that
amber freezy hmm let's see make everyone
wear a mustache
I bought Yaga mustaches today all always
do how many did you [ __ ] boy three left
me Oh Chris Granholm says one that must
be read in a specific way do the Hustle
I'm hit on my big moustache oz nah it's
not sticking sorry we want a Slenderman
game where you can control Slenderman
suggests build a giant bunny wave now to
name yes wait this individuals name is
we want a Slenderman game where you can
control slunt men well if there's any
way to get your message out that
definitely is so good job for you
so apparently black ink with a purple
helmet makes a purple helmet yeah if you
know what I mean
what ooh Ricky Hodgson has a good one
well I'm gonna I'm gonna read it the way
that I read it in my mind because I
think it's better but he says in a
nutshell build basis and then try and
kill each other with arrows artillery
style oh I think that sounds more
exciting than it would probably look
because it would probably look like mark
building a tower and then shooting
arrows at the sky for about 40 minutes
and also it'd take forever to do not
really well what make a nuclear bunker
out of
iron blocks and then test it ah ha that
was those that was a Tekkit thing right
our nukes in regular minecraft do yes
sorry bread constable constable alright
so anyway we're just digging around we
thought we'd give you guys some screen
time how I'm about not wait I'm not
gonna die oh yes you will oh oh I was
falling you well once someone says that
we should spank wade in all caps okay
that was Rachel rexicoricophalvitorius
ooh you got Karen alright [ __ ] for
better a few other case wait bend over
wait wait wait bend over
alright what where's this happening
BAM Oh take your punishment this is
small eyes why did we go German I don't
know why that happened I don't know
Oh y'all take your planet into law oh
you're a naughty boy
alright come here let me hit you with
the chicken so whose suggestion was that
um um because I want to blame them for
what just happened cuz I was really
weird why I wasn't that why did that
just no person who suggested that is
Rachel rexicoricophalvitorius sad man
who the Hopi and paste that name into
the chat just so that everyone can see
I promise because Mark died I was that's
the person that's the one Rock Sakura
kaluza's rock Sakura kapha lappet aureus
that's good though why am i Rock Sakura
click at what you've done Raksha quarry
look at what you did anyway I'm trying
to game I'm about you like she did it
and she contribute are with me right
hahaha you think it's good buddy not you
see it on bad but I might be so speak oh
god no good god oh here's an actually
serious ago k that would actually
seriously be cool we don't do this make
pumpkin pie without cheating since
that's a new thing in 142 I don't know
about that seems weird
alright usual - serious - serious yeah
how do you dig it I don't know probably
with Lumpkins and that some other body
pumpkins a pie [ __ ] get zombie to
spawn over 10,000 guests on every map on
the server so everyone has a bad time
not just you Bob and oh god jack schmitt
you're the [ __ ] man hey
he called you gaiden that is that is
wait that is gay that's totally speaking
everybody it's totally a thing
mark you shall gain it tastefully
offensive to what you heard me ha ha ha
ha ha Kyle born as a actually for
serious funny one he says build a wipe
course or what was have you guys seen
the show wipeout oh yeah ok it's worth
yeah yeah I had Americans all across I
know pennies styrofoam I said wipeout
course [ __ ] why his wife course he said
why God I said wipeout I'm I'm I might
have cut
sure it's not called a wipe course I
guarantee it mmm
also since I was reading it you know
also I'm still trying to read I work in
a public school I know how to reading
there we go
hey I appear to not be able to destroy
things all right
am I to Booty am I to booty so what is
we do it oh no I'm not a puppy
why a what I had a bone and a dog was
following me so I gave it to the dog and
now he's your puppet
you stay away from our puppy yeah you
killed adds up ha ha
oh no oh um that was mostly my mistake
hey looking for me that's enough puppy
Rick it'd be a shame if anything
happened do it I could be late why I
want to fly it's trying to save you from
the arrows I want to fly mmm
poppy red gills got ice got about more
the best Oh what I love your videos and
you're very funny you make the best
lighthouse that you can make you killed
your own puppy you killed your puppy
wait till this one's awesome hilarious
you can't kill me I'm a I'm Buddhist ah
blood fun my computer's radially
bouncing me around
it's your computer still doing that
thing that you hate yes and I can no
longer use the D key to go right man
your computer's falling apart who built
that piece of [ __ ] you yeah wait oh yeah
sorry Bob did we settle on an idea ah no
I'm currently being gang-raped by a
bunch of moms oh is that one of the
suggestions it is what it sounds like
okay one hot air Stilton you know what's
weird wait wait you're weird
ah how did I
I took my little screw my dog you killed
your own counted hey I found a bunch of
black sheep
I made a dog I'm gonna get there we're
gonna slide her oh it's a cow it's not a
dog bear spider here's an idea let's
build a house I feel like we
accomplished that last time I did me it
was pretty much a house it was at the in
terment interesting thing yeah hey I
died I thought we couldn't die we can if
we get blown up all right so we're gonna
build
aha said apparently that's like the we
worst idea and it was a release in about
10 minutes already just reading nothing
I can't destroy things and I'm not even
to the bottom of all your suggestions
huh you have too many too many fans oh
yeah we all have to scare some of them
away yeah no you're a mcconnell says
that I should make something in honor of
mark mark should make something
depicting Wade in the best way he thinks
possible and what you phrase it like
that and wait to jump off a shire half
into a pool of lava ha ha
Kieran McConnell come on down and stuff
kara McConnell come on down what we owe
you see this [ __ ] you in your fur bill
Aziz voice hey that's her name I can do
that I could be the prices right guy huh
arrow arrow arrow arrow arrow arrow
arrow arrow six why I meant it I meant
what I said all right so what are we
doing we haven't decided yet um I'm I
don't know beer we should make a roller
coaster for Wade we've got only three
minutes of yeah we got 11 minutes zombie
you pick either equip us to make a
roller coaster or a house
rollercoaster two of the most creative
fitting soul ever decided oh I thought
that was a mute wad for a second I was
like hey Shannon more like you were
smuggling oh I'm a cook with an egg and
a Carol they're building that I have
anything so you guys know jambe never a
question i'm sabe o
in latin till the ducks zombie i need
permissions and also house or
rollercoaster
chop-chop haha Wow gosh
I barely I clearly demanding when I get
your our heads yeah Latin shows up and
starts killing me incessantly uh yeah
consistently incessantly Oh exist yes
she kills me incest that's what I said
house though wait probably exactly what
I said hmm
boy is that what I sound like oh I'm Way
dumb-dumb whoa hey hey how bad like Bob
oh hey I see a crafting table oh yeah
what do you have oh right Wow apparently
I broke everything I can't break things
my gosh why are there dyed leather
tunics and [ __ ] why are all the switch
is floating none of them are swimming
why are all the rub gone huh I'm not
drinking around actually surprisingly
I'm building a roller coaster ha
that sounded like a rick roll roll akuto
hello well then i trevor gotta i don't
know the verse for the roller coaster of
love song or i would start singing that
was actually synchronized for a second
yeah for one what's naked [ __ ] you think
it was it was not yeah yeah okay
you said yeah like little johner well
we're dealers okay I think that's losers
I don't think that I wanna make this
because that's anything what's a
detective versus a pal you shut up about
your stupid detector rails what job
about it oh I don't know I don't know oh
I know I'm just a big emotion
I can't even dig dirty the stupid it's a
big bubble blowing baby that wait oh no
I still can't destroy things
I play Strachan now it sucks Oh bigger
weird on this server oh not on zombies
server
everyone should plan zombie server which
is definitely located in the description
below are we need to move your head away
okay what is it detective
don't ask Tommy he's not here oh well we
can't areas godly forced to just to us
to this near spawn what this is he can
hear you he can't answer you he can't
save you now Rick yeah um I need more
rail here Oh
Oh are we done oh oh oh I still can't
destroy flies here sigh it's supposed to
be the side that powers to go huh are we
building a completely unpowered roller
coast good Mardon the shot oh sure is it
physically is it physically possible to
build loops a no it is not zom I think
not shouldn't Crete include that
included included yeah the city included
your mom's included no Wade's mom isn't
cruel my track was just magically fixed
yeah thank God for whatever malevolent
force is helping me cuz I suck at this
oh yeah no malevolent I did it again
what did you did I'm [ __ ] idiot that
sounds about right
I mean I can't argue without a shut up
that seems like something that happens
dad I so I'm making this roller coaster
like a like a like what what oh it's
something that it's like no no Ibaka's
pick up bad out of Base Christmas like a
bat out of Christmas yes
love it I said it perfect a thing now
it's a thing everybody's AB like a bat
out of Christmas it's a thing no I did
it again I don't understand let's work
it off
oh you silly [ __ ] uh-huh excuse me bard
me too much beer where is this alright
turn the whale are you like Oh
more rail she is she won't
oh look at cross the village whoa look
across the valley to the other hill that
has rails all over it fish it oh wait oh
wait I see you wait look at me ha ha I
say Marge Marge the aah
I need my hour Oh mark is on my side
wait do you see me morale I'm on top of
the hill I'm a just a hill jumping this
is like the divorce rollercoaster this
ever happened unless it was best roller
coaster that ever happened no that's not
a thing I think it's a thing it's gonna
be a thing ballast I'm building it on
the way to where Belle oh [ __ ] where Bob
where did you say you were mark I think
you need to come and look where I just
filled my roller custard I'm on my way
Danny and you fly no can't I you can
fight him earlier cannot fly flying is
not hiding from from where the chest and
crafting table are I am the opposite
direction of wait I'm straight up the
other Hill or weight is right now in
fact I could care less about where
weight is my roller coaster goes
underground it's all roller coaster baby
your mama it's Logan whoops
mark where are you on the other side of
this island on some below humble
leveling Oh isn't giving me enough rail
oh my god Oh My Damn I hope it's growing
ham a crushes barf to know that what
it's grown ham oh my goodness
Oh My Damn oh my goodness it's going ham
you know you know gonna know don't act
like you don't know know you think we
know but we don't don't sink
you don't know but you did okay you
gonna ah
I'm building Herschel gasm Herschel
oh yes here cut see where you take it
connected like a boughs han oh [ __ ] it's
getting dark where is this go wait no
stop it's not ours madness mark dark
mark dark dark mark dark your dark Dirk
deep dark know it's getting dark
what it's getting I have I have no
torches redstone torches like about I'm
rotting it I'm rotting it complete yeah
the casino where we're going oh my god
who broke it somebody broke it who broke
it
Oh got around the wrong way Oh God I
wish you guys could feel that on my ass
I'm on ill where there's no real oh it's
on real I am underwater where's my car
John cares wait shut up Oh someone made
a door and it did not work out well whoa
what the hell okay I need a mind bother
this sign say rail switcher
0:01 least a certain death and the other
is perfectly okay I can tell you what
one leads to certain death it's the one
that I'll just read oh oh my carbon away
Oh
Carlyle some malevolent douche knock
come on who did that would dick
what what what the who though I no
longer care oh look at me go
can we die of hunger in a shell dude I
don't know I'm all yeah we love you
jelly you jelly bro you jelly bro ha you
jelly kombucha jelly from out well I'm
going the other way now bro
oh yeah huh ah trash talk about wait
wait this whole time
now I'm going the other way again Oh
what the hell yeah [ __ ] you who loves
Gaga almost applause come on oh wait why
you have to be a such a dick
Bob where are you
this is the worst roller coaster could
your work Oh Thank You Dom B for giving
me a push this zombie just gave me a
push that was awesome oh I'm going up
way side of the roller coaster oh I'm
going back now
ah see that's funny cuz you say it's not
true but it is if anyone gets the
reference that I just did 5,000 points
to Gryffindor wait what is so funny
oh I don't know I don't know the
Reverend I just don't know it's from we
I said we I miss all the minecarts
that's lame should have some we start
going backwards what the hell's happened
oh my god I don't know what going on Oh
Bob what is that from it's a Fourier
doesn't understand sarcasm from Family
Guy oh yeah
it's funny cuz it's not true
oh okay apparently on unpowered rail you
stop oh I'm on the side where I die ah
you're fine Bob and the most agonizingly
slow Hill Climb ever who built the
shitty rollercoaster oh I did oh no it
turns around oh it gets stuck oh it does
cuz unpowered rail barely stopped you I
don't know why oh yeah are you guys okay
oh it's so bad at this
I feel fine to me no my cars come back
ah oh man wait
wait stop it I'm trying to connect these
two no it's a swell Amash it's left how
does this happen how do we totally
ignore time and then suddenly we're out
of it
fiercely do you have a minecart Wade yes
can I have it it's full it's over here
give me a boost well then you know one
night go let's go let's go go away
Thank You Wade god damn it you boost me
you gave me a Boosh let me hear my cart
no your iCard kill someone hit the rail
switch someone hits a rail switch hit
the rails are you in a car I am I the
only part for the past 10 minute Oh are
we going you're just sitting we're just
sitting in oh god wait no now wait for
this for my girl Joni sure yeah Keeble
oh oh
son of a [ __ ] Oh God Oh hmm
stop your fake acting wait you're such a
bad actor you such a this is drowning
your sub it sounds more like your
builder booting a porcupine ah well I
don't know what that sounds like but if
you do I suppose that's ok let me trust
Oh God lag lag please could I have a
mind eye on my card got for weary I'm
standing down here at the thingy okay
I'm on my own one year way okay I'm
gonna miss it like it here wrong with
the spare go yeah I'm good I'm gonna
wreck it get it get it you got it
holy crap
mine cart dispenser is happening why I
would love the glasses there's a
minecart dispenser and it's happening
okay I don't know what's up with this
minecart is acting very strangely
don't add me why why did that turn
around again ah no not that way huh I
got a yes Oh God my god in a mind my
game is lagging like seriously I have no
idea why what they keep turning arrests
doesn't make any sense lagging at all
umm I'm lagging like no I'm just stuck
in an infinite loop of sucking minecarts
by you guys so much right down back oh
come back my way oh crap bah that's not
good
my you're gonna die it saved me you hit
me back the other direction yeah alright
well I got a minute left so I'm coming
for you I don't know why I get lagging I
think I think I think I can't have a
rail on the roller coaster really [ __ ]
with my game one rate per second I got
one frame per second I'm not doing well
oh my god I'm flying through the air
real ah oh no oh oh it's happening log I
wish you guys could see my screen right
now I'm on a minecart flying through a
mountain okay blow up I can't even
rejoin the server oh [ __ ] good to see
what's that I can't see the camera is
now off so we're just gonna end the
episode here so thank you all so much
for watching
Clippy I'll take some videos that we've
done and as always we'll see you in the
next video whoa bye bye
Oh